there's this question that's been asked
constantly which is when does China
acquire a sort of industrial design
culture i'm the author of little rice
which is a book about xiaomi the chinese
phone company that's now exporting both
hardware and services globally and what
that what that means for the company for
China for the world it's a book that's
published by the Columbia global reports
imprint so this book is a result of me
getting lost in the Shanghai subway I
got out of the wrong stop and I walked
out into the middle of a mall which is a
completely ordinary current there are so
many malls in Shanghai and when you walk
out of the subway very often you were in
a mall and so wandering through this
unfamiliar place I did the thing that
people are designed confusing malls want
you to do which is I slowed down and
started looking around and there was
this booth selling phones and I needed
to needed a phone at the time so there
was a nice black 13 sleek and stylish
and I was pointed and you know we did
that thing of people who don't share a
common language coming I have some money
you have a phone surely we can work this
out and I walk out of there with us with
this new phone it says me three on it
that's all I know about it and every day
on that campus from picking up the phone
for the next several days if I took the
phone out to do anything one of our
Chinese students would say where did you
get that didn't even ask what kind of
phone it was they all knew it was a
Xiaomi phone that this was the hot brand
which I had not understood when I bought
it and so I would talk to them about it
they said it's the Chinese apple this is
our big design firm you know this these
are the people who are figuring out how
to do industrial design the way Apple
does it the way Samsung does and it was
apparent that this was not an accident
that the phone they made was the result
of years of planning and work and that
they were intending to do it again so I
started tracking them and they just kept
getting more and more interesting and
when Nick lemon who stepped down at the
Dean of the Columbia Journalism school
and as he was starting Columbia global
reports I thought Xiaomi
has its sights set not just on being a
Chinese design firm but on being a
global design for maybe this will be
interesting and that's when he and I
started talking about tracking Xiaomi
spread outside of China as a way to
think about some of the global forces
going on today what shall me I think
shows it that the answer the question
when will they acquire a design culture
is for at least some products 2013 right
that's that's when this the me three
which is the phone that i think was
their real design breakthrough it didn't
look like anything else the market is
very stylish phone that said there are
people inside the company thinking very
hard about design that's part of what
makes Xiaomi such a company to watch in
China so many people have looked too
lazy who's the CEO as an example of oh
that's how we should do it so Chun's
design culture is kicking off now and
will again spread to all of these all of
these other products but what you're
thinking about show me is there there
next phone than me for is very close to
an iphone 5 and then the note which is
my current phone is very much like a
samsung galaxy s5 so the company rather
than saying we are a design firm or we
are a sort of a copying and shipping
firm just operates across the spectrum
and that's not something we're used to
in the u.s. it's usually I you know your
sony or your Apple it's it's all branded
or your asus and acer where you're just
kind of point boxing these these devices
shell me can operate across that range
and one of the interesting things about
the company is is it ever going to
settle down and be designed centric for
all of its product lines or if there's
some advantage to both the kind of
design copying that they have
historically done that many chinese
companies historically done and keeping
a design centric product line at the
same time there in that world now which
to an American I looks unstable but in
fact that may be a new pattern and
that's I think one of the big open
questions for the company